the two offensives one in the north one  in the South the North has moved much  more quickly than the South  um there was a huge element of surprise  but I think it's also came as a little  bit of a surprise of the speed that the  ukrainians were able to move for  themselves  the second offensive though is down in  uh the South Where We Are  the Russians are well dug in they  expected an attack on Curson it'd be  much flag beforehand and the casualties  are high as a result of it and it is  very slow uh progress for the ukrainians  what's interesting is that uh  for the soldiers down here what they're  saying to us they're convinced that the  Russians are really well dug in because  they're trying to defend their positions  and effectively defend Crimea because  from Curson is a sort of Gateway into  Crimea and that ultimately is what the  ukrainians would really love to take  back